What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Welcome to another episode of
Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series
Where YOU challenge US
With your craziest ideas
Related to table tennis.
We will go through all of your comments
Pick the most creative ones
And make a video out of them.
If your idea gets picked
We will feature it
And give you a shout out.
So make sure to leave your ideas
In the comment-section below!
William Stewart wants us to make an around
the net shot
With the edge of the paddle.
This should be no problem!
Next up, Daniel Tran wants us to play with
a mobile phone
And do an around the net shot.
I have a feeling that this is going to be
a good racket!
Let's see.
As I figured
This is a good racket.
Let's see how many around the net shots I
can make.
Dr. Depipreeta Dutta Gupta wants us to make
15 consecutive behind the back shots.
Let's see how it goes.
Our friend Dvysku
Wants us to build a card house
And spin the ball around the net
And between the cards
I tried it out with normal playing cards
But they were not big enough
So I bought these extra large playing cards
And I'm going to build the card house with
these
And see how it goes!
Malte Reichow wants us to play table tennis
with a frying pan.
I started with the knife last time
So I will let you start with the frying pan
this time.
Let's go!
Marek Kowalski wants us to play15 seconds with
2 balls
And we will have to turn around
And switch hands
After each shot
Otto, do you get dizzy easily?
Well, I haven't done this kind of stuff in
a long time
So we will see.
Well, I get dizzy very easily so this is probably
going to feel horrible.
But let's try it out.
But we will first try out with only turning
around
And then if it goes well, we will switch hands also.
That went quite well
And we are still on our feet
So let's try switching hands also.
Thanks for watching guys!
If you enjoyed this extra long episode
Make sure to leave it a thumbs up!
And check out the link in the description.
If you are new to our channel
Subscribe here.
And watch the previous episodes here.
Until next time!